hi out there we are WonderCon I'm Vinnie
Mancuso with collider.com I am joined by
Chris Butler writer director of missing
link and we are joined also by mr. link
I am obsessed with the detail that goes
into to these movies and the end result
of this is complex gorgeous film this
that so much went into it so I'm curious
what's what day one is like when you
have this entire thing in front of you
and you're like I need to make that
happen at some point in the future but
for me it's day one is so far back that
I can barely remember it because all of
this stuff starts with an idea that I
sketched in in a notebook maybe 15 or
more years ago so there isn't like them
really that strict day one I've been
used to these characters I've been
wanting to tell a story with these
characters for a long time
the first day of pre-production or the
first day after you get a green light
that's that's something different
because then you think oh we've actually
got to make this and that that can be
quite terrifying especially when it's a
project that's as ambitious as this one
was it's it's interesting that you that
you wrote the script to but I'm
wondering if there was ever a point
where you're writing something and
you're in the back of head you're like
how am I gonna do this no I think the
thought in the back of the head is how
is someone else can I do this and that's
something that like that they've been
very good in the sense that no one's
ever tried to stop me from writing
something I mean I try to write what I
think is gonna be an entertaining movie
an entertaining story occasionally I'll
think oh I probably shouldn't be writing
this but I think one thing that's being
proven by the studio since I've been
there is that we find a solution for it
for everything so we did the story come
from where did this this idea for the
the sasquatch sort of journey come from
so for me it was you know the the best
movie ever made in the history
the universe's Raiders of the Lost Ark
true no doubt an objective fact yeah
that's right and I think I always had
this kind of thought of wouldn't it be
great if we had like a stop-motion
Indiana Jones and as a kid I was also a
big Sherlock Holmes fan so I thought
okay Indiana Jones meets Sherlock Holmes
meets planes trains and automobiles
that's kind of what the movie is it's a
buddy movie it's this the world's first
cryptozoologist Sir Lionel Frost voiced
by Hugh Jackman and his journey across
the globe
with this guy voiced by Zach
Galifianakis and there is the
performances agree and there's like a
real human element to it and I'm
wondering when you're you're down in the
nitty-gritty and you're figuring out
moving the figures and you need to
figure out the technicalities how do you
remember to you know keep the humanity
of it when you're when you're moving
these these tiny piece by piece figures
yeah it's it's a trick
I think it's probably the most important
thing about directing an animated movie
is the ability to step back because
everything we do is like this insane
amount of detail obsession and we have
people whose job it is for three years
to do one tiny aspect of one tiny thing
and do it brilliantly and I think as the
director you've got to be able to step
back and say what is this shot about
what is this story about what who are
these characters because in the end what
you want on the screen is a story that
contains characters that an audience
will find compelling it doesn't matter
how amazing they look I mean it's kind
of cool but you just want the audience
to be lost in their story and I want to
talk very specifically about about one
scene I won't give too much away but I'm
kind of obsessed with this how it was
done it they there's a there's a moment
on a boat to do an inception thing yeah
how did you do that good question I
remember when we were story boat in that
and I was thinking this is gonna have to
go but that was important cuz to me it's
like why do you do animation
you you you do animation because you get
to play in a stylized version of the
world and so if you have an action
sequence in an animated movie it should
be bigger than than real life so for
this this chase sequence on board a boat
and it's taking place in the middle of a
storm and the boat goes up the side of a
wave so the characters are running on
the walls and the original because
obviously all these things are physical
sets and they're huge like one of those
corridors is the size of this table yeah
that becomes very very difficult to move
around so we ended up moving the cameras
and just on rigs but that actually made
it incredibly difficult for the
animators because they had to imagine
something moving when it was just the
camera moving yeah so not easy because I
was gonna say so what when you're there
on set what is what goes into that
imagining is it oh yeah I mean it's a
it's a lot to do with the skill of the
animator and yes a lot of thought goes
into it a lot of technical figuring out
but you you also sorry completely
microphone it's okay yeah just when it's
a sequence like that where it's you're
sort of having to imagining it what it's
like when it's done but it sits on the
set how do you how do you what's the
process of that well there's a lot of
technical thought goes into it and
obviously it's a lot to do with the
skill of the animator but the other
thing as well that most people probably
don't know is that we kind of rough
through every shot first so if it's a
complex camera move we will do camera
tests and then we will do oftentimes if
it's if it's a complex shot we will do a
block which is where you put you know
the the puppets through very very
roughly what it's going to be doing in
that shot and then we do a rehearsal so
the animator actually does the shot
twice the rehearsal is fewer frames
it's on twos instead of singles but it
gives you the chance to see the
performance and see what's working and
what's not what might need moving in
relation to camera all that kind of
thing so you do get to work through a
shot before you commit to it I'm
interested in the just speaking about
visually the color palette of the entire
thing because you did youdid ParaNorman
which is I think like a much you know
darker looking movie overall what made
you go with a much more brighter and
sunnier and sort of outdoorsy look to
this movie I think it's it's that was
one of the things that appealed to me
about doing this was doing something
very different for us and you know
ParaNorman is darker because it takes
place like 90 percent of it takes place
at night yeah so I definitely wanted to
wanted to do something that was bolder
and brighter I talked about it stepping
out of the shadows because I think
stop-motion often gets you know it
people think of it as like the creepy
animation and it is true you know
there's a rich history of creepy
stop-motion but that's not all it can do
and I think this was me saying look what
else we can do and and because it's such
a vibrant movie we get to visit so many
exotic locations it was it was an excuse
really to get to play with it with a
color palette that we've never really
explored before and I mentioned you know
day one looking looking into the future
now that it now that's done and you've
seen it I'm wondering what stop-motion
all that effort what do you think it
brings that does that is different from
from anything else but why would you say
that the that doing it that way is is
worth the effort I think you know that
it almost goes back to you your
childhood you know when you when you
play with toys and play with dolls and
you imagine them coming to life there is
an element of that this like primal
feeling of seeing an inanimate object
come to life that stop-motion talks to
there's a tactility to this medium that
that is it's real I mean when you think
about it start motion is the closest to
live-action it is real lights on real
objects and that is very hard to
I mean CG does a great job but there is
something about the Kaos are the
imperfection of a real object all these
little fibers and you know when you see
that under real light on a set it there
is something magical about it and it
makes you want to reach in and touch
these things amazing well that's that's
perfect way to send this awful let you
get back to the combi thank you so much
for coming through thank you my pleasure
yeah